Matt Damon sat down with our lauren zima
where he told us how his pal Ben Affleck
is doing after his sobriety slip he's
looking great and he's doing great and
I've been we've been working together on
this screenplay and know he's doing he's
just doing great
I loved Matt you just told this story
about a real fight that you and Ben
Affleck were in together as kids it was
right then that little five-foot - Ben
Affleck tackled this dude off of me well
like out of nowhere I was like a junior
and he was like a freshman but I
remember that was like a big moment
going like this guy is like he will he
will put himself in a really bad spot
for me was that moment a moment where
you knew I got a friend for life in this
guy yeah yeah definitely I mean one of
many moments you know
it wasn't just it it wasn't like
stepbrothers become best friends yep
while Matt Damon needed a little help
from Ben our own matt Cohen held down
the premiere just fine
solo believe it's not one but two Oscar
winners Matt Damon and Christian Bale to
shut down Hollywood Boulevard and send
parts racing in the process you came off
by sand you came into Ford V Ferrari and
you made a unbelievable transition
physically what was your regimen like
eight less do more that's it but I had
to actually be able to fit in those cars
there's small cars it's tight
you ready pumped were you to get behind
these beasts of cars put the pedal to
metal a little bit I've done some of
that stuff in the past for the Jason
Bourne movie
and it's and it's really it is really
fun but I don't think I can get away for
a week to do a driving course unless
it's like explicitly like I'm forced to
do it by the studio it's hard to get a
Hall Pass for that long yeah you can't
just be like come on honey I'm joking oh
it's really important but wait I read
the script
you don't really drive in the movie well
I know but it's kind of in my past I did